and welcome back we're out here at the m
i'll tell you what the raiders have
associated themselves
with many many businesses here in
southern nevada the m being one of them
of course prior to game day
this is where the raiders will stay and
today they unveiled their newest
addition of course it's the raiders
tavern and grill
this place is going to be red hot for
raider fans they'll enjoy this place
certainly will we had a chance to take a
quick peek at this uh
tavern here today silver and black all
the way through they cut the ribbon
earlier this afternoon to be a prize
spot during the season
i don't know how many las vegas raiders
fans really understand
how big raider nation is that
enthusiastic nation but they'll find out
when the season starts hopefully with
fans
but here at the m this has become a
satellite drop-off point
before venturing down i-15 to the death
star
the fan base is going to really embrace
this location
because it's so close to our facility
because it's our home headquarters hotel
and the relationship has been so strong
you see a lot of people here you see a
lot of raider fans here you see
the co-branding of the logos all over
the place hussein and his team have done
a great job to promote them
[Music]
all right so this could be a lot of fun
of course when raider nation gets back
into las vegas guess who is also here
to help cut the ribbon newly elected
hall of famer charles woodson
he was here he's gotten to the wine
business so some of his wine is inside
the
raiders tavern and grill he also has
been back in las vegas to kind of take
in the atmosphere
we had a chance to catch up with charles
woodson this is what he has to say
pretty exciting you know to be a part of
you know
for the whole entire really the raiders
organization to be here in vegas
you know for the end resort to be the
official raiders hotel
and then now to have the raiders you
know tavern and grill opening up
for me you know to me it's a natural fit
right you know i'm a raider
i played with the raiders for 11 seasons
need to have my wine here right
but it's just not that easy you know i
had to i had to go through
the right channels
yes he did and once again he's got his
wine inside the raiders tavern
we mentioned it before this is the very
first raiders
official tavern in the entire country so
it's kind of interesting